♪ ♪ ♪
- Dès les premières minutes
du gala , un artiste
innu était en vedette.
Scott Pien-Picard, originairote,
a participé au grand numéro
collectif d'ouverture.
- Anachnid!
(applaudissements)
- Mais c'est l'artiste
oji-cree Anachnid,
qui a remporté le
d'artiste autochtone
de l'année. Entre tradition
est à mille lieux des clichés
folkloriques associés
à la musique autochtone.
artiste multidisciplinaire
- Moi, vraiment, l
m'a ouvert les yeux
à explorer de nouvellesm.
- Les nouvelles voix autochtones
sont multiples et touchent
à tous les styles,
comme lequi compose du hip-hop .
Q052, rappeur
- Le hip-hop, ça vient du Bronx,
ça vient de New York,
et des places marginalisées,
ça fait es communautés
autochtones, on vit beaucoup
les mêmes choses.
- Des arrgents
talentueux, comme Kanen,
qui s'inscrit fièrementes
qui ont pavé la voie.KANEN,
auteur-compositrice-interprète
- Moi, ciration, c'est Élisapie,
qui m'a fait dire : Ah! Je peux
faire ça, je peux faire
de la musique.
- Tout comme Kanen, Matiu est
originaire de Maliotenam, une
véritable pépinière de talents.
auteur compositeur interprète
- Depuis le plus longtemps q
je sais, tous mes amis
savent jouer un peu de guitare.
puis on "jam" ensemble, puis...
J'étais tariste,
j'étais pas le "lead" guitare
avant, là, autour de la tab
de table, mais là, ça va bien,
fait que je peux pogner
la guitare.
- L'OBNL "Musique
par Manon Barbeau, accompagne
des artistes autochtones
JOËLLE ROBILLARD, directrice
ue, Musiquue, Musiquue, Musiquue
- Je sens que le public est
curieux en ce moment puisue ça r
puis que ça sera pas juste
une mode ou un moment. Je pense
que le défi qu'on a en tant que
c'est de mettre les assises
pour que ce soit... pour
qu'il y ait une pérennité à ça.
- Des artistes bourrés
à dire et qui sont prêts à être
connus eer
comme ils le méritent.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
♪ ♪